la segunda ley de la termodinámica nos
dice que la entropía del universo
siempre está creciendo así que el cambio
en la entropía para el universo cuando
cuando realiza algún proceso siempre es
mayor o igual que cero y demostramos
esto en el vídeo anterior y que tiene
muchísimas implicaciones por ejemplo
éste no importa como definamos la
entropía por ejemplo la entropía
definida como una constante por el
logaritmo natural del número total de
estados posibles que puede tener el
sistema o el cambio en la entropía
definida como el calor agregado al
sistema / la temperatura a la cual fue
agregado
cualquiera de estas descripciones
combinadas con la segunda ley de la
termodinámica nos dice que cuando tienes
un cuerpo caliente que está tocando a un
frío por ejemplo digamos que el cuerpo
caliente tiene temperatura de 1 y el
frío tiene temperatura de 2 que el calor
va a fluir del del caliente al frío es
decir eso lo vimos matemáticamente en el
último vídeo y el calor fluye en esta
dirección ahora
alguien de los que comento en el vídeo
dijo podrían tratar algo sobre el
demonio de maxwell y eso es lo que vamos
a hacer porque es un experimento mental
muy muy interesante que que parece
desafiar este principio y parece que
desafía el la segunda ley de la
termodinámica y por eso tiene un nombre
rimbombante que es el demonio de maxwell
ok que en realidad ya saben o maxwell y
toda la gente que estuvo trabajando en
esto en estos temas estuvieron metidos
en muchos temas así que este es el mismo
maxwell famoso por la ecuación de
maxwell que obviamente pues ya vimos que
trabajó con varias cosas no así que de
hecho también es la primera persona en
crear una imagen a color a la mitad de
los 1800 así que un individuo bastante
picudo verdad pero bueno qué onda con el
demonio de maxwell cuando tenemos que
que estamos pensando con el demonio de
maxwell bueno estamos pensando primero
en la energía cinética de las moléculas
ok las moléculas van a estar rebotando
por aquí
y en promedio tiene una mayor energía
cinética que el cuerpo con temperatura
t2 verdad ahora ojo estamos hablando de
la temperatura como un promedio porque
estamos diciendo que es un macro estado
sabemos que a nivel micro cada una de
estas moléculas tiene una propia
velocidad de una propia propia posición
entonces a lo mejor este va más rápido y
éste va muy lento
este otro va más rápido en esta
dirección este pues apenas si se mueve
ok es un mundo es un revoltijo de
posibilidades y sabemos que los
microestados
podríamos a lo mejor dibujarlos en un
historia por ejemplo para tf1 vamos a
decir que este es en escalas kelvin
entonces digamos que aquí mi temperatura
promedio está aquí pero tengo toda una
distribución posible de temperaturas
para el número de moléculas ok entonces
lo que vamos a graficar es a cada
temperatura asignar el número de
partículas que tenemos que tienen esa
temperatura ok entonces a lo mejor se va
moviendo de esta forma más
como como una campana de gauss jana ok
tenemos digamos muchas moléculas que se
concentran alrededor del promedio y muy
poquitas moléculas que tienen poquita
energía cinética y muy pocas que también
tienen mucha energía cinética así que
aquí aquí hay toda una completa
distribución de partículas de la misma
forma podríamos graficar lo para el
cuerpo con temperatura de dos el cuerpo
frío ok en promedio a lo mejor estos
tienen una energía cinética menor pero
también puede haber moléculas que tengan
mucha energía cinética solo que en
promedio va a tener una menor
ok así que si por ejemplo tuviera una
distribución para el cuerpo con
temperatura de 2 se vería hoy bueno aquí
me equivoqué pero más o menos se podría
ver algo así
aunque ya lo mejor se vea algo así
déjenme intentarlo un poquito distinto
por ejemplo algo así ok
algo de esta forma así que noten que hay
algunas moléculas en t1 que tienen una
energía cinética más baja que entre 2 ok
por ejemplo estas moléculas son estos
que en el cuerpo de dos tienen poquita
energía cinética y además entre dos hay
algunas moléculas que tienen más energía
cinética que el promedio del cuerpo
caliente así que son estos por ejemplo
de acá ok
son estos así que por ejemplo este tipo
que va muy rápido
en fin en fin puede puede haber muchas
cosas a nivel micro pero a nivel macro
el promedio pues es una es un macro
estado no depende del de otra cosa más
que su posición en el diagrama de
presión volumen y lo que dijo maxwell es
bueno a ver suponga bueno él no uso la
palabra demonio pero bueno él se le puso
algo así en un sentido un poco
metafísico digamos pero no
y dice supongamos que tengamos a un tipo
aquí déjenme déjenme hacer que digamos
un zoom al experimento de maxwell
digamos que entre estos dos sistemas que
están que están este separados ok
están separados aquí está de 1
ok tenemos un montón de partículas ya
saben se empiezan a mover con sus
energías cinéticas ok y aquí está de 2 y
estoy haciendo los separados porque voy
a poner una pequeña conexión justo aquí
ok aquí está de 2 y aquí tiene a sus
chicos que tienen cierta velocidad quién
sabe y lo que maxwell dice en su
experimento mental dice bueno supongamos
que ponemos a un tipo encargado de una
puerta aquí
ok y tiene control de esta puerta y
cuando una partícula muy rápida en t2
pasa por aquí cerca de la puerta
digamos que este este esta molécula de
aquí ok que tiene una velocidad muy
rápida y pasa súper rápido cerca de la
puerta
ok va a pasar perfectamente por la
puerta el demonio va a decir dice veo a
ese tipo viene a la puerta abre la
puerta ok y loba le va a permitir pasar
hacia el cuerpo de uno ok entonces aquí
se se queda después de abrir la puerta
pásate uno y después cierra la compuerta
otra vez porque quiere que las
partículas rápidas de t2 pasen a tf1 y
cuando ve una partícula muy lenta muy
lenta ya sabes medio medio medio lenta y
que pasa por la puerta desde t1 él
también va a abrir la puerta y va a
dejarlo pasar a t2 así que lo que sí
permite que siga pasando eso que va a
ocurrir al final bueno al final lo que
vamos a tener que segrega mos
todas las partículas que van lentas
déjenme déjenme dibujarlo aquí está
no está muy claro ahorita que es pero
bueno aquí está digamos la la puerta ahí
están las fronteras de mis cuerpos
entonces todas las partículas rápidas se
quedan del lado izquierdo ajá no importa
ya si se han bueno originalmente eran
algunas de tf1 y otras de t2 pero las
más rápidas se quedan del lado izquierdo
esta es una esto es un dibujo separado
porción todas las partículas rápidas se
quedan del lado izquierdo pero las
lentas debido a que las de t2 no pasan
ok ah bueno por ejemplo aquí tenemos
también algunas partículas rápidas que
eran originales de t2 ok así que tenemos
aquí del lado izquierdo todas las
moléculas rápidas del lado derecho a lo
mejor aquí se quedaron todas las
partículas lentas de t2 baja y además
como dejó pasar a las partículas lentas
de tf1 entonces por ejemplo este aquí ya
del lado derecho se quedan también las
partículas lentas que originalmente
estaban en t1 así que qué ocurrió aquí
que acaba de ocurrir este era el cuerpo
caliente este era el cuerpo frío y la
segunda ley de la termodinámica nos
hubiera dicho que el calor debería ir de
izquierda a derecha que la temperatura
se deben igualar hasta cierto grado así
que el cuerpo caliente debería
volverse más frío y el frío más caliente
pero usando este pequeño está figura
demoníaca que es lo que hizo hizo que el
cuerpo caliente se volvía más caliente y
ahora el promedio de la energía cinética
aquí es mucho mayor verdad ok
toda la energía cinética de estos bueno
no sabemos cuál es pero en promedio es
mucho más alta
ok todos todos estos que estaban del
lado derecho que tenían una alta energía
cinética se pasaron a la izquierda
entonces la distribución se verá a lo
mejor algo así en vez de la original y
entre dos todos los calientes se fueron
hacia t1 entonces a lo mejor estos ya no
existen ya no van a estar ahí y los
agregó a todos los agregó a todos así
que la distribución entre dos se va a
ver de esta forma por supuesto hay que
borrar estos dedos también que se
sumaron ahora al lado izquierdo
muy bien así que estás esas eran las
distribuciones anteriores pero ya estas
son las nuevas vamos a rellenar esto así
que te dos tiene a lo mejor un promedio
algo por aquí no sé ahora está aquí de
dos ahora t1 la temperatura promedio va
a estar por acá así que este demonio
parece haber violado la segunda ley de
la termodinámica aunque esté este
diagrama déjenme déjenme lo copio o más
bien lo enmarcó este ejemplo parece que
el calor lo caliente se vuelve más
caliente y el frío más frío así que el
experimento mental de maxwell acaba de
violar la segunda ley de la
termodinámica y esto de hecho fue como
una adivinanza durante mucho tiempo en
este en este ciclo siglo la gente se
trataba de pensar que era lo que está
incorrecto de este experimento y no lo
voy a probar yo matemáticamente porque
es un poco complicado pero es análogo a
lo de él
al aire acondicionado que vimos en el
vídeo anterior digamos que tenemos aquí
un tipo que de hecho a lo mejor es un
demonio jalando aquí la puerta cuando
cuando se acercan cuando cuando es
conveniente cuando las moléculas rápidas
del lado derecho se acercan y del lado
izquierdo las bajas se acercan entonces
para poder llevar noción de la
trayectoria de todas las partículas digo
no son pelotas no son macro pelotas son
micro moléculas átomos así que va a
tener que a lo mejor arrojar luz hacia
ellas o usar un microscopio electrónico
o va a tener que mantener noción de cómo
se mueven todas estas moléculas estos
millones de moléculas así que debe tener
una supercomputadora ya saben aquí está
su computadora su microchip que seguro
es súper avanzado para nuestra
tecnología y entonces esto estaría
generando
cómputos cálculos y esto empieza a
generar mucho calor este microchip
empieza a generar mucho calor además
empieza a rebotar luz o lo que sea que
empiece a rebotar para tener noción de
dónde andan todas las moléculas y medir
qué tan rápido van estas estas
partículas eso también va a generar
calor y además va a lo mejor si quiere
este mover la compuerta en fin todo lo
que tiene que hacer va a generar calor
así que la respuesta es no lo voy a
hacer matemáticamente pero se puede
hacer que en realidad este demonio este
demonio al usar su computadora sensores
todo lo que hace para para saber este
nivel hasta este nivel para saber todo
el movimiento de las partículas esto va
a generar tanto calor que la entropía el
cambio la entropía va a ser mucho mayor
que el cambio de la tropilla de este
sistema de las partículas así que como
este es un es un cambio de entropía
negativo el demonio de maxwell va a
generar un cambio en la entropía
mucho más grande ok que es un
experimento todo esto muy muy muy bonito
muy intuitivo muy intuitivo de qué es lo
que está ocurriendo a nivel molecular
pero que podría lo mejor ser confuso
verdad podría confundirnos y pensar que
esto es una paradoja o algo por el
estilo cuando pensamos en la entropía
del sistema completo tenemos que incluir
también al demonio mismo y si incluimos
al demonio mismo está generando más
entropía a cada en cada momento que abre
la puerta y quizás está haciendo más
energía para que pueda llevar noción de
dónde están todas las partículas en fin
el demonio de maxwell genera más
entropía que la que se pierde cuando por
ejemplo por ejemplo una de estas
partículas atraviesa la barrera la
barrera verdad bueno como sea
creí que era bastante bueno exponerles
este bonito experimento los veo en el
próximo vídeo